COMMITTEE FOR MONDAY JANUARY
THIRTEENTH ISSUE BY CALLED
ORDER. ISSUED VICE AN AUDIO OR
VIDEO RECORDING TODAY FOR SEEN
AS BEING MADE AS ALSO BEING
TELEVISED- SECTOR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL COOLEY. CUNNINGHAM.
YEAH YEAH LARA. GRAYSON THERE
KAMLAGER-DOVE MAIENSCHEIN
MATHIS. QUIRK SILVA HERE RAMOS
RIVAS IT WORKS HERE. WE HAVE A
CORE. GEN HE IS OUR MOTION.
MOVE MY CAREER SECONDED BY WAS
QUIRK SILVA. MEN'S SECTION
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL COOLEY HI
COOLEY AYE CUNNINGHAM
CUNNINGHAM I. CARILLO I THREE
OH AYE FLORA FLORA. BY RACE AND
I. AM LONGER I'VE MAIENSCHEIN
MATHIS MATHIS AYE QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE ROMAN SIDE FOR
ALMOST AYE RIVAS. RIVAS I
WEBSITE WORKS I'VE MENTIONED
CLASSES THE MOTION IS PASSED
AND THIS RULES CRUISER JR THANK
YOU VERY MUCH